The color of warning signals, smiley faces,
rubber duckies and the Sun (at least from
our perspective- in fact the Sun is white
if viewed from space), for many of us yellow
has a favorable connotation; yet, at various
points throughout human history, yellow has
decidedly been a symbolism of, alternately,
heresy, jealousy, treachery, sin and gutlessness.
It’s not completely clear when yellow came
to represent human weakness and immorality.
In fact, during the Early Middle Ages (5th-10th
centuries), yellow (as a cheaper substitute
for gold) was commonly used to represent divine
light in art and manuscripts, and even Jesus
was sometimes depicted with blond hair.
However, during the High Middle Ages (11th-15th
centuries), things began to change.
Although it’s not clear why the color was
chosen, as part of the Abilgensian Inquisition
(mid-13th century), which started in the 1100s
in France, Cathar heretics who repented were
forced to wear yellow crosses as part of their
penance.
Similarly, Jews, widely despised by other
religions at the time, had been forced to
wear some type of marker since the days of
the Umayyad Caliph Umar II (8th century),
and by the 12th century Jewish men in Baghdad
each wore two yellow badges (one on the head
and another on the neck).
This practice of marking Jews in yellow continued
throughout the Middle Ages and the Renaissance,
with the symbols themselves being variously
rings, circles, patches, strips of cloth,
badges, belts and hats.
By the late 14th century, Venetian prostitutes
were also wearing yellow – a practice that
spread throughout Italy during the Renaissance;
reflecting this, in Renaissance artwork Mary
Magdalene was often depicted in yellow as
well.
By the time of the Spanish Inquisition (1478-1834),
heretics were dressed in tunics of yellow
cloth called a Sanbenito (for Saint Benedict).
Moreover, from the late Middle Ages yellow
had been associated with falsehood, treason
and treachery; Judas was also often depicted
wearing yellow at this time.
By the early 17th century, the negative symbolism
of yellow had expanded to refer to jealousy
as well, as seen in Thomas Dekker’s North-ward
Hoe (1607): “Iealous men are eyther kaues
or Coxcombes, bee you neither; you weare yellow
hose without cause.”
Notably, yellow still retains a connotation
meaning along these lines, today, and particularly
with regard to unscrupulous and recklessly
sensational journalism; its earliest appearance
in an English language publication was The
Daily News (London) (Mar 2 1898): “The yellow
Press is for a war with Spain, at all costs.”
Yellow continued its descent in the late 18th
century when the phrase yellow-belly was first
identified as a xenophobic, derogatory term,
as set out in Grose’s A provincial glossary
(1787): “Yellow bellies . . . an appellation
given to persons born in the Fends . . . who
. . . have yellow bellies, like their eels.”
It’s not clear if this insult was intended
to convey cowardice at the time, but the singular
yellow seems to have by 1856 when it appeared
in P.T.
Barnum’s Struggles & Triumphs, yellow did:
“We never thought your heart was yellow.”
Completing the circle, yellow-bellied for
cowardly was first seen definitively in English
language print in 1924, in Percy Marks The
Plastic Age when he wrote: “Yellow-bellied
quiters.”
It has been suggested that yellow-bellied,
meaning a coward, may have been inspired by
chicken egg yolks being yellow and chicken
meaning coward.
However, this cannot be as chicken with this
definition didn’t pop up until around the
mid-20th century.
An alternate more compelling, yet no less
speculative, hypothesis has it that yellow-bellied,
meaning coward, was inspired by someone with
“guts” being referred to as courageous-
thus those with “yellow guts” (yellow-bellied)
have “fake” courage, borrowing from one
of the former definitions of yellow meaning
falsehood.
This is somewhat plausible as, despite the
fact that for most of the 19th century guts
or gutsy actually meant “greedy,” around
the turn of the century the “courageous”
definition of guts began gaining steam, first
attested in 1893, a few decades before the
first definitive instance of yellow-bellied
meaning someone who lacks courage.